foreign
like to discuss rights of Passage and
specifically we don't have to
necessarily focus on this but this this
is something that often ends up on my
radar of Consciousness because I have
many males in my audience and there
seems to be a distinct lack of Rites of
Passage for men in most
westernized Societies or many Western
societies and I would love for you to
describe a chapter in your life and I'm
most certainly going to butcher this
pronunciation but spots easy
uh did I get that right yes but it's
easy red goat so could you explain what
that is rights of Passage exists all
around the world for a very specific
reason it's not a coincidence
or an accident that they involve pain
you know whether it's scarification
whether it's the severing of the
foreskin whether it's the pain of ordeal
the ingestion I mean for example the
Algonquin speaking of datura their
initiation right was to put the young
Lads in the long house seal it shut and
make them eat datura for two weeks oh my
God so that they would forget what it
was to become boys to learn what it was
to be meant but the reason all these
ordeals that you know so much about
Vision quests Etc have pain is because
the message has to be clear this is the
end it's not about the twiddling of
thumbs we are passing on to you the
obligation of adulthood you now hold the
destiny of our people in your hands this
is not trivial you best be prepared
and I think whether it's with women who
go through their own rituals which are
always sort of timed to the first Menses
or the first period the fertility
transforming a girl into a woman a
potential mother or it's a boy
proving his manhood now this has become
rather you know
frowned upon in our kind of politically
correct woke world but the truth is
young men I've never known a young
Ladd who didn't want that challenge it's
that idea of proving oneself not in a
gratuitously matcha way but literally in
a kind of organic way of grit and
courage and strength and I think that's
why I mean for example I've got very
close friends in the Navy Seals and they
all have a kind of a calm confidence
because they've been on what Joseph
Campbell called the hero's journey and I
think those of us like myself in you
know brought up in a society that we did
not have obvious Outlets we created our
own Heroes Journeys and for me it was
always either through work or travel you
know
you mentioned spats easy well you know I
was living
on Haida Gua in Northwest British
Columbia in the mid 70s and
I was very much critical of industrial
clear-cut logging but I felt that I best
learned something about it so I lied
about my credentials and managed to hire
on as a logging forestry engineer in one
of the toughest logging camps in the
west coast of British Columbia where I
stayed a year and I learned everything
about the business including the
corruption and it was a fantastic
experience because I also learned that
the men and women fighting off hunger
with the chainsaw were not my enemy
I learned that in all of these conflicts
particularly around resources there are
never any enemies only solutions